- We are back
and there are many
sub-genres in country music,
alternative, bluegrass,
honky-tonk, just to name a few.
Our next guest is an up-and-comer
who's passionate about bringing western
back to country music.
He has a new album now and
it's called "White Buffalo."
Now performing "Long Live Cowgirls,"
put your hands together
for Ian Munsick, everybody.
(audience applauding)
(audience cheering)
(soft country music)
♪ She's a gooseneck on a dually ♪
♪ A long neck at the bar ♪
♪ Loves old John Wayne movies ♪
♪ Waltzin' under them stars ♪
♪ She's sun up in the saddle ♪
♪ Cuttin' through the heard ♪
♪ Loves brandin' her cattle ♪
♪ Long live cowgirls ♪
♪ Well, she rode in them wagons ♪
♪ When the Wild West was won ♪
♪ And took the canyons and badlands ♪
♪ And made 'em her home ♪
♪ She's boots on, LeDoux songs ♪
♪ And snaps on her pearls ♪
♪ Long live cowgirls ♪
♪ Woo-hoo-hoo-hoo ♪
♪ Like a paint-colored Mustang ♪
♪ Well, she's fast and she's wild ♪
♪ Stop a runaway freight train ♪
♪ With her high-country smile ♪
♪ She's tough as December ♪
♪ Salt of the earth ♪
♪ Make you fall like September ♪
♪ Long live cowgirls ♪
♪ Well, she rode in them wagons ♪
♪ When the Wild West was won ♪
♪ And took the canyons and badlands ♪
♪ And made 'em her home ♪
♪ Well, she's boots on,
Chris LeDoux songs ♪
♪ And snaps on her pearls ♪
♪ She's been there and she'll be here ♪
♪ 'Til the end of the world ♪
♪ Long live cowgirls ♪
♪ Woo-hoo-hoo-hoo-hoo ♪
(audience cheering)
(audience applauding)
- Ian Munsick, everybody. Give it up.
Get his new album, "White Buffalo,"
wherever you get your music,
and you can also see Ian
performing at Stagecoach
with Luke Bryan, Kane
Brown, and Chris Stapleton
in Indio, California, April
28th through the 30th.
And that's gonna be super easy
for everyone in today's audience
because you're all going
home with a pair of passes
to Stagecoach Festival 2023.
(audience cheering)
That's right.
(Kelly chuckles)